attempt to fulfill his social pledges
joe biden has hit out against
billionaires as he pushes a newly
proposed tax bill that will target the
country's mega-rich
i don't want to punish anyone's success
i'm a capitalist
i want everyone to be able to if they
want to be a millionaire billionaire to
be able to seek their goal
but all i'm asking is
pay your fair share
and right now
many of you are paying virtually nothing
well the u.s tax system is progressive
meaning that higher earners do pay a
higher percentage of taxes it's been in
place since the end of the 19th century
but billionaires have found ways to
avoid the top rates and one way is by
taking out loans against their company's
shares which they are not taxed on as
they don't sell any of the shares they
own the newly proposed wealth tax though
seeks to close that loophole it does
include an annual levy on unrealised
gains made from shares and other assets
it all comes to as the democrats seek to
fund their new multi-trillion dollar
social spending program and is only
expected to affect the very richest in
the country and meanwhile the richest
person in the world elon musk is
understandably not happy with the new
tax proposal currently his annual tax
rate reportedly makes up only three
percent of his total wealth
eventually they run out of other
people's money and then they come for
you it is very common what elon musk
does it's not unique to him billionaires
and millionaires are regularly able to
escape taxes legally because they
support politicians who do that for them
the most recently donald trump in
december of 2017 when he cut their taxes
dramatically and when they can't get
their taxes cut enough legally we know
now from the various uh papers that have
been released the pandora papers a
couple of weeks ago it's a scandal in
this country and what mr musk said is
really outrageous
never have the taxes uh been levied on
the super rich the way they were
intended to
when they passed the taxes the
super-rich went very quickly to shift
them on to the average person and that's
been the history of this country for at
least the last century
you